well i like the old prince harry you
know the one who used to get drunk and
play naked billiards in vegas he was a
lot more fun than this hofe
sanctimonious virtue signaling hypocrite
who just thinks he's perfectly okay to
quit the country quit the royal family
and then make all these demands from his
california mansion about all the stuff
he still thinks he's entitled to he and
his wife are making hundreds of millions
of dollars out of fleecing titles
bestowed on them by an institution they
keep trashing
and i think it's a sickening thing that
they're doing i think it's horrible for
the queen and i wish they would stop
slow golfers are probably the most
annoying people in the history of world
sport golf is slow numbers it is but you
got to keep
the pace of the play and when i'm out
with my mates if i'm playing with
something like kevin peterson who
rattles along quite rightly hold by hold
and we come across a bunch of slow
golfers all taking
hours to get their shot right their feet
right their backside right and then you
watch them and they drill it straight
into a ditch it's like you know what get
on with it you're no good anyway most of
you so get on with it
i used to support the death penalty i
thought that in some cases of sickening
depravity what's the point of mistake
keeping people alive who kill children
or who are serial killers or whatever
the heinous crime may be seemed to be a
waste of state money that could go on
far more important things but then i
interviewed a group of people called the
west memphis 3 over at cnn and they
spent 27 years in prison for a crime
they didn't commit and when i saw them
in the flesh and what they'd gone
through and how their lives had been
destroyed and were only saved in the end
by dna coming into into play which
helped get them out of prison i realized
that actually you you can have a death
penalty if you're 100 guaranteed that
you're only going to kill people who
absolutely did the crime that you are
executing them for and the crime was so
heinous it warrants the loss of their
own life but you can't the system is
unfortunately flawed and if one innocent
person is executed has their life taken
for a crime they didn't commit i can't
support that system and so for that
reason i've actually changed my mind
about a death penalty
[Music]
well anti-vaxxers to me in the main are
ill-informed they're deluded they
believe conspiracy theories as a degree
of selfishness there's a sadness about
it all now we have successful vaccines
most of the people that are ending up in
hospital or dying are the unvaccinated i
feel sad these people have read
something online by somebody woefully
ill-informed or deliberately spreading
lies and it's costs in their life it's
actually a tragedy
the metaverse what does that mean
you